thirty that is still breathtaking in its
pain and grief and tragedy and basically
flat again like many of the other
numbers just in terms of overall context
where where are we where are we going
everybody wants to a dance ask that
question every day and I understand that
we have to get to tomorrow what is the
final conclusion of this ugly chapter I
still believe it's when we have a
vaccine when people know that this virus
is totally controlled that's 12 to 18
months hopefully it can be sooner
maybe there's a medical treatment in
between we hope we pray a lot of medical
companies are working very hard on it
right here in this state and all across
the country that would totally change
the trajectory people who were looking
for a quick fix a quick answer it would
be a medical treatment that would be the
quick fix announcement of a vaccine that
would be a quick fix in the meantime
it's going to be an incremental process
between today and tomorrow as much as
people don't want to hear that that's
the truth you're not going to hear any
day soon it's over the nightmare ends
and we wake up it's going to be
incremental and we have to be smart as
we do this do no harm control the
confection the rate of infection as we
go through this we also have a lot of
work to do operationally in terms of the
health care system and now testing which
I'll talk about in a minute the testing
tracing is the guideposts through this
right as we're working our way over the
next several months the testing which is
informing us as to who can go back to
work helping us isolate people it's
about testing and testing is a totally
new challenge nobody has done this on
what we need to do on testing and then
the ramped up of the economy to the new
normal as we do this again in terms of
perspective I think of it this way our
whole response thus far basically has
been a response to a crisis right and as
the numbers start to come down and as
people start to take a deep breath and
people start to feel we can control the
beast which we can and they they take
comfort in the fact that we can control
the Beast which I do I was afraid this
thing was uncontrollable and that
despite everything we did the numbers
were going to continue to go through the
roof and by the way nobody could tell
you otherwise but we proved we can
control the beast we can reduce the rate
of infection we did that by our response
to the crisis credit to all new yorkers
all americans they flatten the curve
nobody else no government agency no
public health expert people's actions
flatten the curve we responded to the
crisis that sort of all in this first
response the first phase bring down that
infection rate the infection rate was
one person infected one point for other
people that's when an epidemic breaks
out
that's fire through dry grass right
that's what we talked about yesterday we
have the infection rate than 2.9 one
person infects point nine other people
I've never met a point nine person but
the infection rate is less than one to
one that then sees the outbreak starting
to subside the numbers starting to come
down which is what we're seeing in the
numbers so we did that this is all in
our response to the crisis and let's say
it's from minute one to where we are
today
this has all been crisis response bring
down the infection rate we did that
bring up the hospital system to this
projection level which would
impossible but ramp up that hospital
system so when you have all these new
infected people you can handle it you
don't overwhelm the public health system
you don't have people dying in hallways
which is what we saw in Italy on TV
right
that's all phase one that's critical
response hurry up get it done every day
is vital drastic measures taken quickly
in a coordinated way that's phase one
we're still in that phase because you
still have two thousand people coming in
the door every day so don't get cocky
don't get arrogant we're in control no
you're not in crisis because you can
control the beast but you're only
controlling the beast because of what
you're doing that's where we are we're
starting to transition to another place
what's the other place it's going to be
the second half of this situation which
is unpause e
right the situation we're in now is
unsustainable people can't stay in their
homes for this length of time they can't
stay out of work you can't keep the
economy closed forever
you just can't society can't handle it
personally or economically so now we're
moving into another phase which is this
reopening phase how do you plan the
reopening nobody's ever done this before
and how do you plan a reopening of an
economy and at the same time be
cognizant of the public health crisis
that you're still in right we have the
infection rate down to 0.9 one person is
affecting point nine percent with less
than a person okay
the epidemic outbreak percentage is one
point to one person infecting one point
two you only have between 0.9 and 1.2 is
a margin of error we have to reopen we
have to reopen we have to reopen yeah
you only have a very slim margin to
operate
you open too fast you bring people out
too fast you'll get to 1.2 in 3 days and
we'll be right back to where we started
so that's the I want to get out of my
house versus public health balance that
we're talking about what how do you
measure this how do you calibrate it you
have to develop a testing capacity that
does not now exist and then you test
people on a higher volume than ever
before you then trace them to find other
positives and then you isolate them in
the meantime we have to stabilize the
state's finances because we have a
terrible economic deficit we're spending
money every day that we've never dreamed
of spending we're asking all these
hospitals to do things all these local
governments to do things we're paying
and we're paying when we're in a
position where we don't have any money
which is a also an unsustainable
position in life you can't keep writing
checks if you have no balance in your
account it doesn't work long term one
point they come and they knock on the
door I don't know who knocks on the door
when you're a state government but
somebody's gonna come knock on the door
so that's where we are overall the next
frontier is going to be testing we don't
have a testing system that can do this
volume or that can be ramped up to do
this volume we don't have a public
health testing system by the ways its de
minimis if you look at what our
government departments of health have
it's a relatively de minimis capacity
well what's our private sector testing
capacity that's relatively de minimis
also think about what we're talking
about we're talking about labs that
normally operate to do blood testing if
you need a marriage license you have
together
if you have your child is sick this and
the first strep test
the doctor says go take a blood test for
allergies you go when you go to a lab to
have blood drawn that's basically the
system we're talking about that system
does not do large-scale kovat testing
this kovat testing first in and of
itself is a very complicated new test
it's not as simple as drawing blood and
getting it tested this test in and of
itself is complicated and expensive and
you don't have the network that does
that it just it does not exist this is
where we were with the hospitals we came
up with what we call surgeon flex what
happened with the hospitals when this
started we started seeing these much
higher numbers that would overwhelm our
hospital system well how do we ramp up
the hospital system you don't really
have a public hospital system down state
in New York you have about 100 hospitals
you only have about 15 of those 100 of
public hospitals the rest are all
private hospitals voluntary hospitals
but there were private hospitals we had
to get those private hospitals to work
with government in a coordinated way
never happened before extraordinarily
difficult we did it but it was a
phenomenal undertaking you now have 300
laboratories in hospitals across the
state that do virology testing how do we
get 300 private labs and hospitals to
become one system statewide to do
testing for kovat and how do we get them
more coordinated this is something that
has never been done before and is going
to be a tremendous undertaking also to
further complicate it what they will
tell you now because we've been having
the conversations the labs if they can
get the tests
which they have to purchase from private
sector companies the tests require
certain chemical reagents to operate so
you take a sample and then you mix it
with other chemicals they can't get the
chemicals that they need to mix to do
the tests well who has the chemicals no
one has the chemicals because everybody
has been overrun with demand and the
chemicals come out of where China where
everything has come from over the past
40 days everything goes back to China
and China is now in a position where
they're being asked globally for these
reagent chemicals and that is a piece of
the equation that I can't figure out and
that's why the federal government has to
be part of this approach and part of
this answer I can do what I can do on
the state side and I will and I'm going
to issue an executive order that says
the Department of Health will be
coordinating those private sector labs
which are private sector companies but
they are licensed by the state of New
York they're permitted by the state of
New York and we need them to step up and
work together but the federal government
cannot wipe their hands of this and say
oh the states are responsible for
testing we cannot do it we cannot do it
without federal help I'm willing to do
what I can do and more but I'm telling
you I don't do China relations
I don't do international supply chain
and that's where the federal government
can help also remember the federal
government at the same time is
developing testing capacity so we wind
up in this bizarre situation that we
were in last time 50 states all
competing for these precious resources
in this case it's testing and then the
federal government comes in and says to
those companies I want to buy the tests
also this is mayhem we need a
coordinated approach but
when the federal government and the
states second thing that is of a meeting
the concern is we have to stabilize the
finances of the state the federal
government has passed three bills to
address this crisis of those three bills
the state governments have gotten
precisely zero zilch nada in
unrestricted aid the state should this
the state should this the state should
this yes well what support have you
given the states none I mean how can
that even be how is it even plausible as
a strategy it doesn't work we need
financial resources to stabilize the
states because when you starve the state
governments you know I still eat dr.
Zucker still eats but we can't fund
schools we can't fund hospitals we can't
fund small business we can't fund all
these extraordinary efforts that were
undertaking it makes no sense we need to
support the states because the states
are the ones who are doing this
reopening is up to the states right
that's the federal decree it's up to the
governors the governors will decide the
states have to decide everyone is in a
different position and it's up to the
states which I agree there also happens
to be the Constitution but put that
aside I also think it's the right
approach okay it's up to the states but
then don't ask the states don't give
them this massive undertaking that has
never been done before and then not give
them any resources to do it that's not
how this is going to work
the expression don't pass the buck
without passing the bucks
AJ Parkinson mark remembers him don't
ask the states to do this it's up to the
governor's up to the governor's up to
the governors okay is there any funding
so I can do these things that you want
us to do
no that is passing the buck
without passing the box passing the buck
which is the opposite of the buck stops
here
the book doesn't stop here I'm passing
the buck and I'm not passing the box I'm
not giving the financial assistance to
actually perform the responsibility so
last point is we go from today to
tomorrow but we talk about the new
normal
this also has to be an opportunity where
after this horrendous period that we
have gone through on every level
after the exorbitant cost of this the
personal pain of this the death of this
this has to be one of those moments in
time when we look back where we say
society transformed it was a learning
and growth and transformational period
where growth and evolution was
accelerated yes Society took a terrible
blow but it became a moment of
reflection where all sorts of new
reforms and innovations happened that's
what we have to do with this period when
they look back at it so our goal is not
let's get up and turn the machine back
on and keep going the way we were know
how do you make the changes now that
you've been talking about in some cases
for years by the way but you never had
the political will to do it or it was
too hard or was too difficult we talked
about environmental changes that we're
gonna make but we never really do it we
talk about issues of income inequality
but we never really get there you know
we talk about changes to a public
transit system but it's too hard it's
too controversial all right well now you
have an opportunity in this window to
really make changes in
reforms and improve things in a way you
have it and by the way if you went
through this and you went through this
pain and aggravation and suffering and
you didn't learn well then shame on us
then shame on us because there are so
many lessons to learn and then you come
back better than you were 9/11 New York
took a terrible beating this nation took
a terrible beating we learned from it we
grow we're better 9/11 transformed the
country if I told you before 9/11 you
were gonna take off your shoes when you
went to an airport before you could get
on an airplane and they were going to go
through every bag and every you would
say I'm never doing that 9/11 said this
is a different world look at all the
security measures we now have post 9/11
that we would have never envisioned we
were through hurricane sandy we didn't
build back what was you build back
better than before you take that moment
you learn that lesson and you improve
Society we have to do that here and we
have to do it affirmatively it doesn't
just happen you have to say let's we
paused New York pause you paused you
reflect you learn you grow and you move
forward look at what we learned about
the public health system you know what
we learned about the public health
system there is no public health system
capacity hospitals had the number of
beds they needed to operate well what in
case of an emergency there was no
emergency capacity in hospitals nobody
had beds left empty oh that wing is in
case there's an emergency then we would
use that wing didn't exist why not well
that's not what we did so how do you
improve the public health system how do
you improve the emergency response what
we never had to deal with a pandemic
before by the way what is a pandemic
okay well now
did and now let's learn and how are we
going to be ready for the next situation
like this because there will be another
I don't know what it is I don't know
when it is I don't know if this virus
comes back in a second wave but there
will be something and we have to be
ready and better for it and not just
what you learned but what have we been
talking about doing that we should be
doing that this is now an opportunity to
do we've talked been talking about
reimagining the workforce and workplace
does everybody actually have to drive in
to the office every day or did we learn
that there are ways to telecommute and
work from home where it's actually more
efficient it's actually more effective
what do we do about a transit system and
how do we make it safer not just the way
we've been talking about but also from a
public health point of view and how will
we now smarter about public interactions
I can't tell you how many doctors now
have come to me and said you know I've
said for years we shouldn't be shaking
hands that it's just a total way to
transmit germs and viruses etc so how do
we take this moment since we are paused
anyway and actually come back smarter I
also believe it'll work it's a moment of
personal reflection you know we've been
in a different circumstance we've been
in a different circumstance visa vie our
family what have we learned during this
heartbreak and during this crisis I've
spent a lot of time with my kids
22:25 twins 225s the my interactions
with my kids had gotten so superficial
over these past few years you know
everyone's busy busy busy so what do you
need everything good you need anything
from me when do I see you I miss you
the same conversation like over and over
and over now I got time to sit with them
and really have in-depth conversations
that I hadn't had in a long time and
I'll tell you one of things I learned is
I was missing a lot you know they're not
4 5 6 7 10 years old anymore
they're grown up and they have complex
lives and complex feelings and complex
situations and you don't understand that
or get to appreciate that when all you
say is how's everything
anything you need when do I see you
again you know well I was busy
it's my defense to myself I was busy I
was busy
yeah except that's not an excuse and
take a deeper reflection on what's
important in life and you can't have a
real quality relationship with your
child or another human being unless you
take the time to get below that surface
and really understand the person and
really take the time to talk through
what's going on people don't work that
way they don't open up in a four minute
conversation so now I wind up in a
situation where I have a couple of hours
to talk to one of my daughters and
there's a whole person and life and
nuance that's going on that frankly I
had been oblivious to I'm not going to
let that happen again I haven't been
able able to see my mother she's a
little older and I see a lot of people
I'm exposed to a lot of people I don't
want to go see my mother because she's
in a vulnerable population and I'm out
and about a lot so it would be perilous
to go see her now but I think about all
the times I have said to her she lives
in Manhattan
she said can you come over for a cup of
coffee today
how many times I've said yes I'll come
over for a cup of coffee and then called
back and said I can't do it today next
time next time next time next time why
well if something came up I was busy I
didn't have the time wrong wrong that
was more important than anything else
sometimes you don't miss something until
it's been taken away and it made me
rethink what was important and what was
what I had been missing I've been
missing a lot because all this we're all
busy we're all busy we're all busy yeah
what does it mean at the end of the day
you know what did you really what were
you really busy with and did it matter
so I know that I've learned a lot on a
personal level but we may be more
physically distant for the foreseeable
future the key is to be more connected
more connected individually more
connected as a society more connected as
a community and that's what we're going
to do questions you're asking for let's
do a New York pause moment and let's
take this situation and reflect on it
and find a better way here's my
suggestion rather than everybody's
shouting let's I will call on every
person and ask a question and then we'll
go on so we don't have to yell at each
other
Jessie federal funding presumably to
kind of help reopen and restart the
economy do you have any idea what that
number is are we talking tens of
billions of dollars hundreds of millions
of dollars what would you like to see
come from Washington well we know what
we proposed right National Governors
Association which represents governor's
all across the state country all the
governors are part of the National
Governors Association Democratic and
Republican National Governors
Association chairman is chairman Larry
Hogan Republican
chairman I'm the vice chairman I'm a
Democrat
we have publicly requested five hundred
billion four states we've publicly done
that so that's the number that's public
put out in the press release and that's
what it is we didn't get into the
allocation but the allocation should be
proportionate to the need right this
allocation 500 billion for the state's
well how do you allocate it among the
states allocate it proportionate to need
you know where the covet cases are you
can look at a map you see the cases you
know that because you see when the
president talks about reopening
different states are in different places
yes different states have radically
different situations when it comes to
number of cases so allocate the funding
where the problem exists you're trying
to solve the kovat problem allocate the
funding to where the kovat problem
exists and pass the bills where they've
done healthcare funding for quote
unquote Ovid you've seen the numbers
some states got about two hundred
thousand dollars for every Kovac case
New York got about twelve thousand
dollars for every Kovac case how do you
justify that well because it's the
Senate they wanted to give every state
money so every senator had something to
go home and do a press release about
yeah I know but if this state didn't
have any colvett cases how much did you
give that state of taxpayers money just
so that senator could go home and do a
press release give me a break you can do
a press release with you know you don't
need billions of dollars to do press
releases the president said yesterday
that some states would would start to go
into phase one almost immediately how
far away do you think New York is from
like phase one or even phase two well
phase one phase two it's what he's
saying is depending on where that state
is well but the president's saying is
it's up to the states it's up to the
governors the governors who have states
that have fewer cases can reopen faster
yeah that's it has nothing to do with
the president or federal policy or
anything
holy saying is it's up to the states and
you'll see states that have less of a
problem opening sooner that is
undeniable and totally logical so it
depends on that state where it is and it
depends on the numbers and the
governor's rely on numbers and there's
nothing to do with the federal
government I thought when do we reopen
we are now 0.9 on the infection rate 1.2
is the tipping scale where the numbers
start to go up again
right so your margin of error right now
is between 0.9 and 1.2 you have many
states where the infection rate is de
minimis we're at point 9 we're right up
to that line of possible outbreak so the
states that will open first by the data
will have much lower infection rates
than we do we were over the line we were
in outbreak territory right we've gotten
that down to 0.9 but your margin of
error is between 0.9 and 1.2 and what
the experts will tell you is 0.9 1.2
you're right on the line it's not that
precise of Science Hospital rate that
seems to be stabilizing and ticking down
a few questions are you there for
stopping some of the things you've done
increase capacity like the field
hospitals on the Iowa
and then is there any thought
particularly in upstate areas of
reopening hospitals and facilities to
elective procedures there are reports
that workers are being laid off and then
finally you know we had to reduce PPE
standards we had to waive a bunch of
requirements to increase this capacity
will any of that be now willed back and
is there any concern that reducing these
standards particularly PPE may hasten
infection or caused problems among
healthcare workers you know there's lots
of infections there the CDC reduced the
PPE guidelines not to do alphabets
alphabet soup but it was the CDC that
had federal guidelines on the personal
protective equipment and they have
different guidelines apparently when
you're in a crisis then normally they
went through crisis guidelines and
that's what many of the nurses
especially are complaining about you
each actually sets the policy I don't
know they said the policy we use the CDC
guidelines on these issues but about use
of masks BP equipment two gallons we
continue to use but the issue is how
when can a healthcare worker go back to
working with a mask changing this and do
you have any concern that this may have
caused higher infection rates I don't
feel it would cost higher infection
rates at all very health care workers
have worked extremely hard to protect
themselves and to make sure there isn't
any further spread we are not first you
take all these numbers with a grain of
salt right caution is you could have a
surge you could have a second wave look
at Wuhan look at China look at Italy
went up went down went back up be
careful but are we at a point where we
are now immediately in danger of
exceeding the hospital capacity we
developed no that's why we're in a
position to give back give away
ventilators or lend ventilators to New
Jersey other states etc so I don't
believe we are in
place today where we are at risk of
going over capacity yes we have not done
those calibrations yet this is all the
rate of infection analysis is very
difficult and there are a number of
premises that they're making in the
calculation so we don't have discrete
rates of infection
[Music]
look it's important to get the economy
open wherever you can as soon as you can
whenever you can people had a nice break
and they were in their homes I think
everybody is well past I had a nice
break I want to get back to work I have
to get out of the house I love my family
but I have to now get out of the house
and I need a paycheck and I need it
yesterday so everyone is in that same
position at the same time people will
say I don't want to go out and get sick
and die right so that's death is bad and
even those thing at the home and not
getting a paycheck is bad it's not as
bad as death right
that's the yin and the yang here so as
soon as we can and lower infection rate
places lower death rate places are in a
better position than places with a
higher death rate higher infection rate
so yes calibrating those differences is
important and balancing the economic
need and the personal need with the
public health need and death that that
calibration is is everything I think
you'll see it clearer you know we're
right on the line now across the board
you'll see clusters in Upstate also
you'll see nursing home issues in
Upstate one of the reasons they keep
asking about nursing homes nursing homes
are the vulnerable point the the
vulnerable population in the vulnerable
setting a nursing home and we've seen
that across upstate so it's not just
about yes everybody wants the economy
running but everybody wants to be safe
at the same time and that's what we're
working through
these nursing homes that have outbreaks
we're seeing some number is about to you
know 55 deaths just one nursing home at
least 21 facilities on this ellipse I
have over 20 residents my first question
is why
you know the taking so long to inform
the public about this in their
communities
yeah I think they have we've been
talking about nursing homes every day
for the past 30 days the first outbreak
was in Seattle Washington which was a
nursing home that's how this country was
introduced to it we've said 157 times
the most vulnerable neural population
our seniors the most vulnerable place in
nursing homes so I think we that
happened with special precautions for
nursing homes I think we've been talking
about it all along it's not an
inspection issue we've taken radical
measures visa vie a nursing home no
visitors I mean just think about how
harsh a policy that is no visitors in a
nursing home these are people who live
for visitors no visitors staff testing
different cleanliness procedures more
equipment but the virus is nothing to be
underestimated and the virus is very
good at killing and the virus is very
good at killing older people and people
with compromised immune systems and
that's why the virus seeks out nursing
homes
even with the screening protocols now
know that many people consume attics you
can have a temperature base building
event carriers of the disease is there
any for mass testing and nursing homes
or - yes yes that's what we've been
saying also right we want to test
frontline workers test health care
workers but then you need tests and
that's why we've been talking about
testing and the need to ramp up testing
and how difficult it is for testing our
cope in nineteen cask force which which
is balancing load for hospitals has also
been working on the nursing home piece
as well so there have been cases where
some of the residents of one nursing
home have transferred either to a
hospital or to another program that's
something we balanced across the systems
particularly in downstate New York where
this has been more prevalent in the
number of cases the ideal would be if
you had an on-the-spot test person
before they walk into a nursing home you
do a saliva test positive negative
get the results in 15 minutes and if
they test positive but they don't walk
into the nursing home test all the staff
tests everybody who walks into that
building tests all the residents that's
the ideal you don't have that test and
you don't have that volume of testing
capacity and that's what we're dealing
with
seventy-four personal privacy was a key
concern these are all nursing homes with
cases with a greater than five number
anything with fewer than five deaths
were not included in these additional
rounds this is what was been this data
is reported directly from the nursing
homes themselves so if there's any
exclusion that should be included from
the nursing homes themselves and will
circle back as we do every day on
getting updated reporting data from
those nursing we only know what they
tell us what about family members you
want to get information about their
loved ones that are having trouble an ER
seing home you're saying people called
the nursing home for information on
someone in the nursing home in the
nursing home won't give them information
H had put out guidance saying that
nursing homes should inform family
members when there are positives either
in the nursing home in general or
specifically their family member what we
found through the critical reporting
that's been going on through this
process is that's being ignored so we're
doing an executive order that says that
they are mandated to do it and there
will be penalties if they don't
mr. mihika is in charge of reviewing
drivers
yes DC is still is still reviewing that
so we didn't get actual requests last
time you asked a question there had not
been a formal request into ESD there is
now so this was we do have people who
represent the state in China for trade
point of view we've been using them to
help us try to figure out the supply
chain issue which is just you want to
talk about lessons learned we need masks
they're made in China
we need gowns they're made in China we
need face shields they're made in China
we need ventilators they're made in
China okay we're past that phase now
we're on this new phase we need testing
agents they're made in China
it's just how how and these are all like
national security issues when you're in
this situation but we do have people who
work for the state in China who helped
us with trade relations they were
helpful here but in truth this is so
much beyond that level you have the
federal government going to China to buy
supplies you have Illinois California
New York Italy South Korea everybody
going to China and it was well beyond
the capacity of our reps
no servicing right now we're really
struggling across the state and they are
looking to the federal government for
assistance but there's also state
lawmakers that have introduced a couple
bills that on the state level things can
happen have you thought about doing
things like the 60-hour workweek for
example for farm employees or any other
changes to help farmers on this we're
looking at all of that again many of
those bills require state funding and we
don't have it to the extent a bill
doesn't require funding but can be a
part of the reopening plan we're looking
at all of that and I'm open to all of
that and also Mayor Bill DeBlasio saying
that beaches and pools should be shut
for the rest of the season do you think
this is too soon to say yeah look I
talked to a number of Upstate officials
and yeah everyone wants to do everyone
has their own ideas I get it and I
respect it and we have 700 school
districts we have 699 opinions on when
to open schools and close schools and
the school district officials feel that
their opinion matters most and I
understand that we have upstate county
executives who want to open beaches one
open parks etc these decisions are all
interconnected right and this is the
conversation I have with them you know
you open your schools as one district
well then what does it do to the
next-door district and if we don't
coordinate this it's going to make a
situation worse for everyone same thing
with beaches you open your beaches but I
don't open my beaches my people are all
going to go to your Beach right we're
two counties let's say and what you do
with your beaches affects me and one of
us does something and the other one
doesn't now we have a problem and it
could be beaches it can be parks it can
be hiking trails it can be school
it can be any of these things so the
first place we started here was in an
emergency a governor or issues executive
orders that say we have to coordinate as
a state in an emergency more so than
ever before that's the concept of an
emergency declaration why does the
president get more power in an emergency
declaration because it's an emergency
so we have an emergency so what you want
to do with your Park normally yeah it's
up to you but in an emergency what you
do with your Park can affect what
everybody else does with their park
because you have all sorts of people
dying to get out of the house I find
that your parks are open you can have
people come from across the state to
your part now maybe you want that or
maybe you don't want that but I get a
lot of calls from people in the
Adirondacks they don't want a lot of
people coming from downstate to the
Adirondacks and flooding their community
right now so what one does affects
everyone so schools opening businesses
parks beaches all these decisions are
need to be coordinated on a statewide
basis and local governments I get their
concern we all have to cooperate and yes
we'll make decisions will make them
collectively but they have to be uniform
on a state level because there's then
actually a higher level I then have to
turn around coordinate with New Jersey
and Connecticut and Massachusetts and
Delaware and what are we all doing and
how does it work together if I don't
what I do on my beaches in New York
makes a difference to New Jersey makes a
difference to Connecticut they just call
today we have an issue
on they wanted we have different
policies on marinas so people from New
York are going to other states because
other states have their marinas open and
we don't have our marinas open
so within flooding their marinas with
our people sounds like a silly small
issue but these things are all
interconnected so they want to know even
on like marina openings we should have
the same policy otherwise people want to
get out of the house it's now summer
they want to go boating well you can't
do it in New York they all go to
Connecticut kinetic and then says well
this doesn't help us we don't want all
these New Yorkers coming up here to do
boater so they have to be coordinated I
understand it's inconvenient but every
decision has an impact on everybody else
I'm not crazy about having to coordinate
every decision with New Jersey and
Connecticut etc because it's always
easier to make your own decisions and
everybody can be on their own that's not
where we are so no one can make a
decision without the state signing off I
don't make decisions without talking to
my partners in New Jersey Connecticut
and the rest of the Alliance and that is
the best way for government to operate
right now well it's a pain in the neck
yeah I get it I get it
well I like the old way where I do
whatever I want in my County yeah I know
I understand that we won't want to get
back to the old way but we're not at the
old way right now
she's where we second I'm gonna come
right back Bernadette penny mission yes
they here two very different with very
important messages one is to keep COBIT
out of nursing homes but secondly the
March 25th directive from the Department
of Public Health stating that no nursing
home to deny re-entry or admission to a
nursing home based on testing positive
for copa90 Norris or suspected piece of
code nineteen why not they're asking
send them to alternate locations where
they can get better together or insist
on negative testing results yes
dr. Johnson's so I would start by first
mention many of those individuals who
have gone to the hospital because they
were ill and then they left to go back
to their their nursing home which is
their as we've said before which is
their home the so that's the first thing
you want to bring them back to that area
testing for someone who's had code by
coronavirus obviously is something which
would be down the road a little bit to
do as well but we have been looking at
all the possible ways to make sure that
those in the in the nursing home are
protected both the health care workers
and surely the individuals who are at
most at risk also second question will
you answer both the tracker the Kobe
tracker on the website the last update
for the number
simple fatalities in the state of New
York was 2004 77 and the date but it was
most recently updated was April 14th
when might we expect so on the second
Jim you have the data on that April 15th
data will be up today there was some
reporting issues from the nursing homes
for the 16th because we're a lag today
so we'll try to get that all up in the
next day or so
yes we've got some reports from certain
hospitals down state specifically
Manhattan and queens about overwhelmed
ICU beds and just staff they're just
completely overwhelmed wondering if you
guys are going to be focusing more on
these high needs hospitals and then also
maybe utilizing more the Javits Center
and USNS comfort and I also wanted to
get your response it looks like the
president is also watching this press
conference he tweeted 13 minutes ago
quote Governor Cuomo should spend more
time doing and less time complaining get
out there and get the job done stop
talking we built you thousands of
hospital beds that you didn't need or
use gave large numbers of ventilators
that you should have had and helps you
with testing that you should be doing it
goes on a little bit more so wondering
if you could respond to that and then
also the question about the overwhelmed
ICU let's respond to the president first
of all if he's sitting home watching TV
maybe he should get up and go to work
right
second the let's keep emotion and
politics out of this and personal ego if
we can because this is about the people
and it's about our job and let's try to
focus on that I have said repeatedly
that when we were fighting for the
additional capacity for a hospital
system that the president moved very
quickly and I applauded him for it and
he brought the Army Corps of Engineers
and he brought them up to build the
Javits Center capacity 2500 beds
he's wrong that it has been used about
800 people have gone through Javits
to dismiss 800 people is disrespectful
but we didn't use 2500 beds because we
didn't reach the capacity when he says
well we built it we didn't need it
it sounds like suggestion is well it was
requested by the state that wasn't valid
if he didn't really believe 2500 beds
was necessary I don't believe the
federal government would have helped
build 2500 beds and the the number came
from a projection from him him say he
should read the reports he issues the
White House coronavirus task force had
enormous projected in the millions of
people the CDC which is the president
projected in the millions of people so
the projections were high they were the
president's projections so for him to
say to anyone well you've relied on
projections and the projections were
wrong they're your projections mr.
president so what we foolish for relying
on your projections mr. president
CDC coronavirus White House Task Force
that's you White House that's you we
relied on your projections okay
shouldn't have relied on your
projections actually I think the
president has a better argument which is
yes we built 2,500 beds because the
projections said it could get that bad
and because we work together we flatten
the curve and we didn't hit the
projection which is actually what
happened but don't suggest that anyone
made a mistake relying on your
projections
or on Cornell Columbia McKinsey etc
second I have said a number of times I
don't know what am I supposed to send a
bouquet of flowers they were very
helpful on Javits they were very helpful
on sending the US Navy ship comfort they
were very helpful in intervening with
China and getting PPE equipment out of
China they were very helpful in helping
us find ventilators I said thank you
thank you thank you thank you now going
forward we're still in the midst of it
the president doesn't want to help on
testing
he said 11 times I said the one issue we
need help with it is testing
he said 11 times I don't want to get
involved in testing it's too complicated
it's too hard I know it's too
complicated and it's too hard that's why
we need you to help I can't do an
international supply chain he wants to
say well I did enough yeah none of us
have done enough we haven't because it's
not over so yes thank you for the Javits
thank you for the US Navy ship comfort
but it's not over we have a lot more to
do and no one can take the posture well
just say thank you for what I've done
and I'm now out I'm not doing anything
else I've done my part
what if I said to the people of my state
okay I'm done by the way I saved
hundreds of thousands of lives I
flattened the curve I created more
hospital beds than anyone ever imagined
I coordinated the entire state I'm done
I'm done I'm going home I'm gonna go see
my mother I'm gonna spend time with my
kids and I'm gonna go out fishing in
Connecticut because they're marinas are
open that's it I'm done what if I said
that that's what I say I'm done I don't
want to help on testing testing is too
hard and then the only thing he's doing
lets me
well it's up to the states to do reopen
by the way was always up up to the
states what are you gonna grant me what
the Constitution gave me before you were
born it's called the 10th amendment I
didn't need the president in the United
States to tell me that I'm governor and
I didn't need the President of the
United States that tell me the powers of
a state people did that Alexander
Hamilton Thomas Jefferson James Madison
they are the ones who gave me the power
and I don't need the president United
States to read the Constitution for me
maybe he should have read the
Constitution before he said he had the
power to open the states when he did a
very graceful 180 and many people
allowed him to do the grace for 180 but
so he now says it's up to the governors
which he said repeatedly now yesterday
version of yesterday and now it's up to
the governors to reopen okay I'm gonna
reopen I get it and you don't want to
help on testing which is a national
problem and replicates the same chaos
that you created with medical supplies
because FEMA wasn't ready by the way I
needed a stockpile
where was your stockpile ten thousand
ventilators for the nation that was your
stockpile where your projections the
federal projections said they would need
doubled the hospital capacity of this
nation think about that the CDC says
double the hospital capacity of the
nation the minimum projection was 2.4
million hospital beds you know how many
hospital beds we have in this nation
900,000 his projection says 2.4 million
hospital beds the whole hospital system
is only 900
and his stockpile has 10,000 ventilators
you were ready with your stock pile
didn't you read your own CDC projection
didn't you read your own coronavirus
protection so thank you again mr.
president for the jabots thank you for
the corona by for the US Navy ship
comfort which by the way is just doing
your job as president it's not really
thank you like you wrote a check
yourself but thank you for that
we're not out of the woods we have to go
forward we need help on testing and we
need funding it's up to the governors
it's up to the States
well then provide the funding no they
only want to pass a bill that funds
their small business fund or PPE there's
more business program we need to fund
the small business program but you're
going to say if they're just saying this
monumental task is up to the individual
governors and the individual states I'm
providing no help no assistance no
financial money I understand that small
businesses need the funding by the way I
know that airlines need a bailout but
not the states why don't you show as
much consideration to States as you did
to your big businesses and to your
airlines right first he said it's up to
the states that's what he said and if
you say it's up to the states and you
just hold up a big microphone they can
listen to all the governor's you'll hear
some governor's say I can start to
reopen right away because some governors
are in places where
they don't have a serious problem they
never did by the way some states never
even closed down so if you're in a state
that has a de minimis issue yeah then
you can open up faster you can open up
tomorrow or you can start opening up
tomorrow he's doing nothing he said it's
up to the states it's up to the
governors which is what her always was
because it's always been the governor's
power and then he says this is a 50
piece puzzle no no no that's called the
map of the United States it's not a
puzzle and those lines are called States
and those states have constitutional
power remember the way this whole thing
starts the colonies create the federal
government not the other way around so
introduction to constitutional theory
and policy the states have the power to
open the states are opening on their own
timelines we're trying to coordinate
with our neighboring states Western
states are coordinating middle states
are coordinating all he's doing is
walking in front of the parade but he
has nothing to do with the timing of the
parade right the governors are going to
open when they think they should open
all I'm saying is there's two things
they need help from they need help from
the federal government two things help
on testing because states can't do that
and I don't want to redo the mayhem of
the PPE debacle second point we need
funding to do it and the way you love
talking about how you funded everything
big businesses are all getting bailed
out airlines are getting bailed out bail
out bail out bail out all with taxpayers
money state governments which are the
only ones who are doing this whole
reopening they're gonna need funding
right and we'll show grad
dude how many times do you want me to
say thank you but I'm saying thank you
for doing your job this was your role as
president okay so that's the honest
statement of fact without politics I'm
not running for anything I have no
agenda but delivering for the people of
this state and without ego you want me
to say thank you thank you for doing
your job in helping build Javits and
sending the US Navy ship comfort thank
you for participating in a modicum of
federal responsibility in a national
crisis which you know is a national
crisis because he declared a federal
emergency so thank you for having the
federal government participate in a
federal emergency and thank you for help
building Javitz 2,500 beds
pursuant to your projection your
projection and if you don't agree with
your projection fire the head of the CDC
fire the White House coronavirus task
force people because they did the
projections in case he forgot or didn't
read his CDC report just to be precise
March 13th March 13th so we're well into
it CDC says 162 214 million Americans
infected that's over half the population
CDC 2.4 million to 21 million Americans
hospitalized 2.4 million
bottom number 21 million Americans
hospitalized
March 13th the c-d-c 2.4 okay let's stay
there long number two point four to 21
which is a hell of a differential right
either two point four or ten times two
point four thank you for that great
projection but anyway let's take their
minimum number two point four how many
hospital beds do you have 900 call it a
million so it's two and a half times
what your capacity is right where the
state of New York we have a 50,000 bed
capacity by their projections what do we
need a hundred and fifty thousand beds
by the way what did Mackenzie say that
we needed one hundred and forty thousand
beds they got it from the CDC as it says
on the screen they got it from the CDC
that's why we built 2,500 beds at Javits
because we listened to you mr. president
and if we were foolish for listening to
you then shame on us but read your own
report next time before you criticize so
right now we're looking at our cache
numbers our priorities right of making
payrolls making sure we're funding
Medicaid making sure we're funding the
pandemic we have the resources to do
that but we're putting in place cash
spending controls to make sure that we
can do that especially because of the
delays in the tax filing dates so
because that moved from April 15th to
July 15th number of people that filed by
April 15th
seven million when we usually get about
ten million who would file that's about
thirty four thirty percent off those
that file they're probably getting
refunds so the ones that didn't file are
most of that revenue so we anticipate
all that memory news gonna move to July
will be off about ten billion in cash
flow so we're gonna put in place
spending controls actively right now to
make sure that we can continue on a cash
basis we will have to make reductions as
the governor has said multiple times we
have a revenue shortfall even after the
cash flow decline of between ten and
fifteen billion dollars we'll put out a
financial plan that reflects that and
then we'll have to make reductions in
the event that there is not federal
revenue New York City put out their
budget yesterday they were predicting a
revenue shortfall of seven billion
dollars all right again ours looks like
it could be up to double that number and
in the absence of additional federal
revenue when we will have to make those
reductions and that's consistent with
others with other large states are see
me a second excuse me a second Jimmy who
asked the question right we were simply
let people up a chance carrots do me a
favor can you put up the white house
coronavirus projection just so the
president can read what he said who
didn't where will reactor Joseph
talk to you first we were doing three
different things there we're working on
the issues of making sure that they have
the necessary equipment they all the PPE
is when they ask we provided to them
we're also increasing on the issue of
testing and we're also increasing
staffing and I think that's the three
most important things and if there's any
questions we address that we also have
something called a KO video which is an
actually a virtual way to go through the
nursing homes and to look to make sure
that all the necessary things are being
done the proper ways of doing
hand-washing is happening the proper
ways of putting a gown on taking off
gown it's happening whatever we need to
do to help those individuals in the
nursing home we we have we have staff we
have obviously there are volunteers that
that we have worked with as well and a
big pool of volunteers but we're working
with each individual nursing home to
address that would you finish no sir
well if we we've contact them if there's
need for PPE we look we have stockpiles
we have supplies that we have and
obviously masks and other equipment as
well
there's the April 10th directive let's
go
this is excuse me one second this is the
you saw the CDC projections this is the
federal government's white house
coronavirus task force January March 3rd
31st of the projections 1.52 2.2 million
deaths without mitigation 100 to 240
best-case scenario that's the
president's projections so mr. president
if you want to point fingers
which i think is a mistake you're in the
middle of the game it's only halftime
don't be a Monday Morning Quarterback at
half-time never works out well and if
you want to point fingers we built more
beds than we needed our only mistake was
than believing your numbers and
believing your projections if that was a
mistake then I'm guilty but I thought
New York state relying on what you said
would have been a safe assumption I
won't make that mistake again
and it was your CDC and your White House
coronavirus task force that made those
projections who didn't ask a question
sir
- that my friend is a good question
I think it's logical to think a
reopening plan would take into
consideration the differential in
infection rates and overall
hospitalization rate it is a metaphor
for the nation right certain states now
have a much different problem than other
states if you have less of a problem you
can reopen faster
that's essentially true and if you are
in one state and parts of the state are
in a different situation than other
parts of the state why can't those parts
of the state open sooner I think they
can
how much sooner when how do you do it
how do you phase it in how do you do it
in a way that doesn't complicate or
compete with the other parts of the
state that are doing it now you start to
get granular and it starts to get tricky
and that's what we have to work through
but the overall premise I agree and then
you watch that infection rate and you do
have parts of the state that are in a
fundamentally different situation than
downstate now even those counties that
are in a different situation remember a
county if you're looking for a region to
open because a county sometimes is hard
but if you're looking for a region you
don't really have regions in this state
that have been immune because nobody's
immune so you'll see pockets in almost
every region you know you talk about
Western New York or central New York or
Mohawk Valley you'll see pockets in
every region you can find a county that
is in a different situation but what we
have to think through is even if you
started - if you did that if you said
okay that County starts to open up what
happens
to all that pent-up demand from the rest
of the state of people who are dying to
get out of their house and would you
create inadvertently a problem for that
place where you'd see all sorts of
people descending there because that's
now opened right the first barber shop
to open you know there's gonna be a line
going out the door the first hair salon
to open right the first we were
literally on the phone with my
colleagues
Marina to open you know it's gonna so
that has to be thought through and that
has to be coordinated and we are on the
cusp we have to start to deal with these
issues but we're just coming out of
we're still in the midst of a public
health crisis and just because the
numbers are flattening you know let's
not take our eye off the ball can you
put up the navarro memo just for kicks
just to make your cdc coronavirus task
force and mr. peter de Navarro's memo to
the president which the president said
he never read Peter Navarro says 100
millions of Americans could be infected
as many as 1 to 2 million souls could be
lost so whose projections were wrong
head of the CDC Peter Navarro and head
of the White House Corona task force
fire them all that's what I say
fire them you know that show with what
the President did you're fired
if he wants to fire someone for
projections retake his TV career boughs
of the three documented so if he wants
to blame someone for the projections
blame the CDC Peter Navarro and
whoever's on the coronavirus task force
because it's their projections
can you explain a little bit why this
got under your skin today you obviously
are not pleased with what the president
said no no to what he said but why white
this particular criticism you guys have
trade traded barbs in the past but yeah
well this is an important moment he's
saying he doesn't want want to provide
funding to the states and he doesn't
want to help on testing and I can tell
you the states can't do it otherwise and
if this testing doesn't work that's a
serious problem I don't care about his
politics but if we don't have federal
help on testing that's a real problem
and I'm not going to go through the
chaos that was created last time on PPE
where people who were genuine heroes
couldn't get PPE because there was a
lack of coordination and because
everything was made in China we're
looking at that situation with testing
again I can tell you that I know enough
to know that we didn't ask a question
you have the last one we're not there
that's what we have to work through
we're what and when where what and when
thank you guys I'm going to work
[Music]